so yesterday the sun
went dark the earth shook and trembled
fire raged across the land consuming all
in its wake the screams of the forsaken
masses could be heard rising up with the
smoke horror of horrors the ultimate
nightmare
had come to pass
elon musk
taking control of twitter
the twitter corporate board had for so
many years before this
hugged twitter's users tightly against
its bosom protecting them and rocking
them softly to sleep each night but that
was all over uh yesterday
it abandoned them abandoned us all to
the cold in the night where there will
be wailing and gnashing of teeth and
lots of memes also presumably twitter
has officially accepted elon musk's
offer to buy the company for 43 billion
dollars
now tragically the company will be run
by a billionaire
as opposed to before when it was run by
different billionaires elizabeth warren
made a good point when she tweeted
yesterday
this deal is dangerous for our democracy
billionaires like elon musk play by a
different set of rules than everybody
else accumulating power for their own
gain we need a wealth tax and strong
rules to hold big tech accountable
yes it is dangerous to have a
billionaire in charge of a social media
platform that's why those of us who are
so upset by this turn of events and who
absolutely refuse to use a site that is
owned by a billionaire now must
deactivate our accounts
and give all of our business to facebook
and instagram and tick tock instead
you know the ones that aren't run by
billionaires
but i think the real question that we
all face now is how do we explain this
to our children
you know i've already had the difficult
conversation last night as i was
weeping in the living room which is my
usual nightly routine of course
my three-year-old pangender child
moonbeam came in and asked matt
with elon musk taking over twitter will
hate speech be normalized
is our democracy in grave peril
is our country on the verge of
destruction is life even worth living
anymore
and i looked back at them and answered
yes yes yes and no
and then we simply held each other and
sobbed uncontrollably
it was sad yet beautiful
a beautiful moment with me and moonshine
or whatever my fake kid's name is in
this joke to be honest originally i'd
plan to keep the sarcasm going for the
entire opening monologue
but then i realized that that would
deprive me of the opportunity to gloat
more openly and blatantly uh which is
what i really want to do so i'll switch
gears here and instead i'll let the libs
speak for themselves
fortunately nazi propagandist libs of
tick tock has compiled a few authentic
lib reactions to the news from tiktok
and well here's how they're taking it
[Applause]
you know they really make some good
points actually
it would
possibly be slightly easier to
understand if we listen to them one at a
time though so uh let's do that instead
well
it looks like twitter's gone they
accepted the money
and elon stalin is taking over so [ __ ]
you twitter and goodbye forever you
insane q-like
forum
or soon to be insane like you like forum
peace out bye
elon musk
this is directly to you
enjoy twitter i just deactivated mine i
will not be reactivating it
enjoy i deactivated my account and
deleted the app
that's what i think of it
elon musk
today twitter has announced that they've
been bought by
elon musk or
however you say his name um
i'm not interested in staying on twitter
anymore because of this and i think
there's a lot of people that are about
to leave
so i just wanted to
let everyone know that you can find me
here i'm gonna also share this on
twitter before i deactivate my account
so that anyone who wants to follow me
can find me here as well
hey
i did a thing today
i deactivated my twitter account
you can too
on second thought that wasn't much more
coherent i suppose though i'm sure elon
musk is devastated by the incisive
searing wit of these tick-tock libs i'm
not sure how he'll ever recover from you
know things like elon stalin
uh indeed i i bet he's now rethinking
the whole thing now that we've learned
that um at tammy clove at queenie bella
and af at snurfyboo are leaving the site
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content